The Legend of Zelda breath of the wild
unpacks a lot of story across its fast
play time it's an epic narrative that
kicks off 10 000 years in the past
before coming to a suitably heroic
climax within the depths of Hyrule
Castle adding to the mix a whole load of
key story beats told via flashbacks and
there's a lot to reacquaint yourself
with so whether you played breath of the
wild back in 2017 and want a story recap
or just jumping into tears of the
Kingdom let's break down the story so
far
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so the story of breath of the wild
kicks off a long long time ago like ten
thousand years before the main events of
the game we are well past the era of
myth a time where the rest of the Zelda
Timeline takes place for more info on
that make sure to check out my Zelda
Timeline video and Hyrule has now
entered an age of prosperity thanks to
the technological advancements of the
sheikah tribe the realm of Hyrule is
ready for just about anything and
anything turns up in the form of the
revived Beast of Ganon the boar-like
alter ego of the legendary demon Thief
Ganondorf using the technological might
of the sheikah which includes an entire
Army of tentacled robots called
Guardians and four giant kaiju-esque
machines known as the Divine beasts the
princess of the royal family and the
chosen hero are able to repel Ganon and
he sealed away underneath Hyrule castle
and with the job done and in a bid to
subdue the sheikah tribe's technological
dominance the king of Hyrule orders for
the Guardians and the Divine beasts to
be scrapped which results in them
getting buried deep underground the
kings are full though and clearly hasn't
paid attention during highly in history
lessons as that Ganon lad is most
certainly coming back and the King will
need those giant robots anyway peace
extends across the lands and the King
will probably be long dead by the time
ganon's back so what does he care
all right Ten Thousand Years passed by
and this brings us to about 100 years
before the main events of breath of the
wild the story of the fight against
Ganon has become the thing of Legend a
tale of the big bad Boogeyman told to
scare the villains Hyrule while far from
the technological Powerhouse it was in
the days of old is still a great Hub of
civilization and into this magnificent
realm is Born the latest incarnation of
Princess Zelda the joy of her birth for
the royal family and the people of
Hyrule is tempered somewhat though by a
prophecy from a local fortune teller who
foresees the return of Ganon and the
devastation of Hyrule but there's also a
note of Hope in their message with the
news that the power to oppose Ganon can
be found deep underground thank hylia
then for Princess Zelda whose Royal
bloodline has typically provided her
predecessors with sacred ceiling Powers
crucial to repelling the big boy himself
however when Zelda is six her mother
sadly passes away and takes all her
knowledge and experience of these powers
to the Grave all of which leaves young
Zelda in something of a pickle without a
tutor to help her she struggles to
awaken her powers despite several
pilgrimages to Sacred Springs dotted
around Hyrule and with her powers
failing her Zelda throws herself head
first into researching the ancient chica
technology which helps her build an
understanding of other avenues to help
defend Hyrule with Zelda doing her
absolute best amidst dire circumstances
the king orders for the search and
excavation of the Divine beasts to begin
in Earnest the first to be found are the
beasts situated in Gerudo Canyon and
Zora's domain which Spurs on the hunt to
find the others and with a team of
researchers trying to figure out how to
actually use them the search then
extends to find four Champions that can
pilot them and the team that's finally
assembled includes princess mifa of the
Zora daruok of the Goran ravali of the
Rito and arbosa chief of the Gerudo but
wait there's one more piece to the
puzzle and that my good friends is our
hero link this latest iteration of the
legend legendary hero is something of a
country bumpkin who has worked his way
up the ranks of the Hylian Army just how
he came into possession of the favored
Master Sword isn't exactly detailed but
it's definitely a fair few years before
he's appointed as Zelda's personal
Knight he receives this distinguished
Honor by defeating a renegade Guardian
during a trial run at Hyrule castle and
that rounds out the team that stands in
the way of ganon's inevitable return
are you sure positive
all of which brings us to the Day of
Reckoning itself while returning from a
pilgrimage at the spring of wisdom the
Champions witnessed the devastating
return of Calamity Ganon and his initial
Onslaught is Relentless not to be
overcome by the Guardians once again
Ganon sends out waves of pure malice
that possess the stores of Guardians
kept underneath Hyrule Castle in giant
chica pillars Harold castle and nearby
Castle town are absolutely devastated
and countless hyruleans die almost
immediately the king included shocked by
the Carnage taking place before them
link Zelda and the four Champions
finally spring into action with Link and
Zelda heading to face off against Ganon
himself while the Champions head to
their respective beasts Ganon is no fool
though and he fires off giant blobs of
malice to take control of the Divine
beasts these blobs manifest themselves
as Phantom projections of Ganon who
square off against the Champions before
killing them and sealing their Spirits
within their giant metal monsters so far
so brutal
with Hyrule Castle a literal hellscape
Lincoln Zelda turn face and Retreat to
the relative safety of Fort hatano link
is an absolute boss right up to the very
end successfully shepherding Zelda to
safety while taking out a handful of
Guardians in the process but the man has
his limits his strength finally gives
out on route to Fort hatano and he gives
in to his inevitable demise at the
onslaught of Ganon but in that moment
Zelda rushes to protect him and that's
when Her Sacred power finally awakens as
the Triforce of wisdom presents itself
on the back of her hand the light
stretching forth from Zelda
incapacitates the Relentless March of
the Guardians and Stems the flow of
their destruction buying the pair some
time
with Link at death's door a mysterious
voice talks to Zelda from within the
master sword and guides her on what to
do next the sword prompts Zelda to get
linked to the shrine of Resurrection to
allow him the time he needs to heal his
wounds while Zelda tracks back to return
the Master Sword to its pedestal in the
forest under the watchful eyes of the
great Deku Tree the sheikah take Link's
comatose body to the shrine to reclaim
its strength and with Zelda's power
fully restored she heads off to Hyrule
Castle to confront Calamity Ganon where
she is able to suppress his power and
stop his evil invasion of Hyrule
open your eyes
wake up link okay we're a good whack
into this video already and we're only
just at the beginning of the main story
of breath of the wild after a century of
Slumber link awakens completely
revitalized well when I say completely
Revitalize I mean in physical terms his
body has been healed but his memories of
his former life are totally gone
fortunately the sheika who left Link in
the shrine of Resurrection have left him
with a sheaker slate a little Gadget
that coincidentally looks exactly like a
Wii U or a Nintendo switch if you're
squinting the Slate holds photographic
memories from Link's past which are
there as guiding lights for him to
refine his way in the daunting landscape
of Hyrule either way link ambles on down
from the shine to the nearby ruins of
the Temple of time where he bumps into a
mysterious old Wanderer this old boy
regales link with the story of Calamity
Ganon and the present circumstances of
Hyrule notably that the four Divine
beasts have recently started causing a
ruckus across the realm he directs links
to reactivate the great Plateau Tower an
ancient chica monument that restores map
data to your slate and gives you some
stunning views of the world to boot
before aiding link and establishing the
sheikah Slate's full Powers via four
local shrines how does this lad know so
much well that's because he's only the
spirit of the long dead King with this
Revelation the king implores link to
come to the aid of his daughter Zelda
who's still locked in an intense battle
with Calamity cannon in Hyrule Castle he
gifts link a Nifty paraglider and points
him in the direction of kakariko Village
before evaporating away and so Link's
Epic Quest truly begins you must hurry
link
link makes his way to kakariko Village
there he meets impa ashika Elder who's
one of the few people that know the full
story about Zelda and Calamity Ganon
imper delivers Zelda's message to link
which instructs him to free the four
Divine beasts and take the fight back to
Ganon and while you can technically
tackle them in whatever order you choose
let's start with the elephant in the
room literally
link heads to a nearby Zora's domain
which has largely been Untouched by
ganon's Carnage due to its location deep
within the Eastern Canyons of Hyrule but
the Zora's luck is at an end however as
the Divine Beast varuta so named for the
legendary Zora princess who aided the
hero of time has started rampaging in
the Eastern Reservoir and is threatening
to flood and destroy the entirety of
sora's domain with the help of the
topist of top Lads Prince seiden link
manages to gain access to the giant
elephant before defeating the Phantom in
Residence and reactivating the Divine
Beast to Aid in the destruction of Ganon
from Zora's domain link travels north
towards the imposing site of Death
Mountain Home to the mining communities
of the gorans chief among these
communities is Goron city which has also
gone unscathed from the great Calamity
and has now become a thriving Hub of
industry but the salamander-like Divine
Beast varudania has somewhat put a stop
to all of that from its perchertop Death
Mountain while an active volcano is
concerned enough the Beast has started
firing out giant balls of flaming magma
as well which you know makes the place
even more inhospitable link rocks up in
flame resistant armor no less and chats
to the Goron Elder Bluto about the issue
and long story short he bought the
Divine Beast kills another Phantom Ganon
and Bob's your uncle and other Beast is
on the good side
next up on the Divine checklist is the
flying Beast van Meadow which is soaring
among the clouds high above the Western
mountains of Hyrule directly below the
metal Monster's flight path is rito
Village home to the bird-like Rito tribe
as the Divine Beast is shooting down
anything and everything that comes into
close proximity the tribe can no longer
move freely through the skies around
their own village which you know isn't
exactly ideal after a botched attempt to
board the flying beast from a pair of
renegade Rito whippersnappers link
enters the scene to offer his support
and Link with the help of one of the
young Rito Lads soars into the sky
disables the Beast kills another Phantom
Cannon and restores peace to Rito
Village and its surrounding mountains
all of which leaves one Divine Beast
left and that's the giant camel stomping
around the deserts of Gerudo causing
huge thunderstorms the Gerudo desert has
largely gone Untouched by the Carnage
caused by Ganon but that doesn't mean it
hasn't got its fair share of problems
Chief among them is well the chief young
and inexperienced lady riju struggles
with controlling her ranks of Gerudo
soldiers and after a failed Recon
attempt to get more Intel on the Divine
Beast van naboris a sacred treasure
known as the Thunder Helm is stolen by
The yiga Clan Enter link who's disguised
as a woman because no men are allowed
into Gerudo town he AIDS lady riju in
finding and retrieving the Thunder Helm
which handily grants him the lightning
resistance needed to get close to the
rampaging camelbeast he does so often
another Phantom Ganon and Hey ho the
camel ceases its mad stomping and sets
its sights on Hyrule castle and Calamity
Ganon
[Music]
and with all four Divine beasts wrestled
away from ganon's control link is ready
to take on the calamitous monster
himself but before he does so there are
a few more errands left to sort first
things first is the small matter of the
whereabouts of the fabled master sword
after exploring Hyrule high and low link
tracks it down to its location in korok
forest and after being deemed worthy
retakes possession of the iconic blade
foreign
[Music]
but wait there's actually one more
Divine Beast still to tame and well it's
a little different than the others
yep the story DLC expansion the
Champions ballad actually takes place
after you've freed the four Divine
beasts but before you take on Ganon the
Champions ballad sees link journey
across Hyrule tackling various trials on
the behest of a monk called Maz kosher
on Route link bumps into Cass a Rito
Bard who's compiling his Masters
unfinished song and inadvertently helps
his feathered friend finish the verses
after completing the trials and besting
the monk in combat link is gifted with
the master cycle zero and is let loose
on the unsuspecting horse riding people
of Hyrule before he can tear up the
realm though Cass stops link to Regale
him with the now complete song which
triggers another recovered memory in
which all five Champions are officially
knighted at Hyrule castle and with that
happy reminiscence fueling him link
heads for a climactic battle with
Calamity Ganon
[Music]
link enters the festering Runes of
Hyrule castle and guided by Zelda's
voice finds the Hideous beast in an
inner sanctum nestled away in a cocoon
to build his strength Calamity Ganon
wrapped into an immediate battle with
link but with the able support of the
Divine beasts piloted by the freed
spirits of the long dead Champions link
is able to overcome the foul monster but
defeat only makes Ganon angrier and his
pure hatred and Malice transforms him
into the giant dark Beast Ganon which
starts storming around the open field
surrounding Hyrule Castle to Aid Link in
this final battle Zelda presents him
with the bow of light and the pair
overcome the giant ball before Zelda
seals him away forever an actor that
finally brings peace back to the lands
of Hyrule
and as Lincoln Zelda survey the scene of
their dramatic Victory they immediately
get to work planning the rebuilding of
Hyrule while Zelda admits her powers
have dwindled over the century she's
been holding Ganon at Bay she can find a
link that if everyone works together
they can restore Hyrule to its former
glory and on that note of wonderful
positivity breath of the wild draws to a
close I hope you've enjoyed this story
recap guys thank you so much for
watching and I'll see you next time
[Music]
foreign